apple's new macbooks have smoked the
intel models they've replaced they've
smoked windows ultrabooks that cost even
more money they've smoked high-end rtx
graphics windows machines and now it is
time to put it head-to-head against my
15 000 mac pro and don't worry we'll
make this as quick as possible to make
it the least painful for this mac pro
and for myself for buying this mac pro a
couple years ago now here are the specs
side by side so you guys could check
them out this mac pro is 15 g's with 192
gigs of ram the afterburner card the 12
core processor and the vega 2 graphics
with 32 gigabytes of memory compared to
3 500 for this m1 max macbook now this
thing right here also comes with
speakers it comes with the 1080p webcam
it comes with microphones it comes with
this amazing display whereas this thing
well it doesn't come with any of that so
that's another at least couple grand but
up to about seven grand if you want
apple's pro display xdr and some nicer
speakers that's a huge price difference
now let's just get right into the
carnage here we're gonna start out with
geekbench five the single core score
obviously gets killed by this macbook
it's way more powerful and then on the
multi-core side surprisingly this
macbook also defeats it and that is on
battery power now when we jump into
metal the graphics test my vega 2 here
scores over a hundred thousand compared
to 68 000 so it's 47 more raw graphics
performance it has 32 gigs of memory
just for the graphics card where i have
32 gigs for the whole system right over
here and of course it draws a lot more
power well now we'll see what this
actually means in real world results
both in photo editing and video editing
in xcode and other real world tests now
for simple tasks like web browsing the
macbook destroys the mac pro and it's
funny to say hey it's faster at web
browsing but you do notice it every time
you're on one system and the other one
is just so quick at loading web pages
stuff does actually load slower even if
your internet is fast on the mac pro now
that might also be because the ssds are
so fast on this system the write speed
is pretty much twice as fast and the
read speed is approaching that as well
even though we do have one terabyte on
both of these machines now if we
completely max out the systems with
cinebench's 3d rendering benchmark
you guys will see that the mac pro does
actually have more overall performance
we're seeing about 15
more there
now that is pretty impressive so the
overall cpu power is still higher even
for the 12 core model now if we take a
look how much power that uses i was
shocked to see that the mac pro drawed
218
watts at peak for the cpu compared to
our macbook which maxes out at 30 watts
that is over seven times the amount of
power needed and of course the macbook
comes with the battery so you can use it
on the go now the next thing that
absolutely shocked me was the
performance when gaming when the mac pro
came out it was the fastest gaming
machine of course it was super expensive
but now with this off-screen test that
is sphere the macbook's 32 core graphics
get 51 percent more frames per second
and that's on battery power that is
incredible the efficiency now all we
need is some good mac games there's a
few that are optimized and perform
extremely well but we need more now for
those of you guys that work with music
this is one area where the mac pro
absolutely destroyed previous macbooks
and this time with these new chips the
macbooks get very close but the macro is
still 25 percent more
powerful it can handle a lot more tracks
more plug-ins
very very great results for the macbook
more than good enough for anybody and
this is the new logic benchmark you guys
can search it up find out exactly what
is being tested and stacked there and
for those of you guys that work with
xcode my goodness this performance is
insane
we have maximum hermenco's benchmark
that's a big compile and our mac pro
this thing took 125 seconds it was super
fast when we got it
the macbooks only took 94
seconds to compile it that is insane 33
faster of course on battery power and
it's crazy how is it this fast one has
way less ram cp performance is 15 lower
if you're maxing out the cpu which it is
well it's just optimizations with the
unified memory architecture that's
working insanely fast now fun fact for
you guys if you buy the most expensive
mac pro which will probably be at least
20 grand without upgrading graphics or
other stuff
well that one if with a good amount of
ram that one takes 90 seconds that is
the fastest system for xcode this
macbook 3 500 bucks you can walk an
apple and buy it this thing takes 94
seconds that just blows my mind now for
those of you guys that edit photos
the mac pro was insane because of a six
channel memory a lot of ram that really
sped things up as far as photo editing
they're both super smooth but when it
comes to export the mac pro does still
win it took a one minute 11 seconds and
used 46 gigs of ram when exporting that
so more than the system has together
compared to 121 so it's close um the
previous macbook would be like three
times longer than the mac pro so it's
getting close but it does still get
beaten now i would not pay 15 grand or
maybe 10 grand in order to be slightly
faster and then for those of you guys
are making previews same thing
the mac pro is faster in this case it's
actually quite a bit faster i'm not
really sure why maybe previews uses more
ram now on the flip side some of you
guys asked us to test out affinity and
we did i ran their built-in benchmark
and the mac pro got killed they have a
combined score here and for the cpu the
macbook was eight percent faster but for
the graphics it literally was over three
times faster i don't know what's going
on i don't know how they optimized this
program for these machines
but the performance for some of these
tests that they they run in this
benchmark it's insane so for those who
get to buy a macbook definitely check
out affinity photo instead of like
photoshop there's a lot of great
alternatives that are much better
optimized and now let's get into 3d
rendering this is something we didn't
test last year and i thought man with
this graphics card 32 gigs of memory in
here it should kill it right well take a
look at this for the splashbox benchmark
the macbook is 62
faster this is insane to me
i don't know is it the memory that's
making it much faster all that crazy
band with 400 gigabytes per second i
don't know what it is you guys let me
know if you work with this it's using
the ev engine here and then when you
switch to the party tug file you can
download and test yourself
this is over five times faster this is
using mostly the graphics it's not
optimized for metal yet but it's so much
faster on the macbook it is just
insanely fast on these new macbooks and
then if we switch over to the cycles
engine which takes a lot longer in
general
it is higher quality especially if you
want to do super detailed lighting here
the mac pro does be out by a couple
minutes about 25
faster
full 100 cpu so that is actually a very
impressive performance gain and now
let's switch over to what we do all the
time every day and that is video editing
and guys i just want to say
i still had hopes for this mac pro
i thought that in some of these tests
it's gonna do a great job because it has
lots of raw horsepower
but i was wrong
jumping into hevc stabilization the
macbook was twice as fast it has really
fast decoders
really good graphics performance and the
mac pro is just limited with this old
amd graphics card even the newest
6900x graphics cards those have the same
encoders and decoders they're still
limited by that now when we go to export
you see the mac pro was fast but the
macbook killed it a minute and 19
seconds for a five minute color graded
project
insane performance and i was like
alright well we're not going to do any
more easy stuff right this has fast
decoders and encoders let's take it a
step up and switch to canon r5 422
10-bit footage this stuff right here is
really tough a lot of new cameras are
coming with this codec because it's very
high quality and the macbook plays it
back perfectly where the mac pro is a
stuttering mess because it doesn't have
the right hardware to work with this and
then because of this exporting five
minute color graded project is about
four times slower on the mac pro than
the macbook the macbook just kills it
over four times faster actually all
right let's just go with something
really tough i don't want to make this
video editing section too long let's go
straight to the ak
canon raw not real light canon raw tough
footage you need cpu performance which
you know under 100 load it's faster here
you need gpu performance it's maxing
everything out and look at the results
here guys the macbook exported more than
two minutes faster i was not expecting
that i was like what's going on it
should be being killed right and so i
thought about well i'm exporting the
prores this is a high quality video file
i usually go to prores for something
high-end like this
and maybe i'll just switch it to h.265
because we have prores encoders with
this system with the afterburner you
still don't have those encoders we'll
talk about that in just a bit and i was
shocked to see that even then it still
beat out the mac pro with h.265 and for
this crazy test it still kills it i'm
like all right well what can we do you
know this is using both the cpu and gpu
what if we need a codec that really
pushes that over 100 000 score for the
metal for the graphics well that's 8k
redraw um now as far as playback we do
see a difference um pretty much the mac
pro is almost perfect it's not perfect
at playing this back at full quality uh
the macbook it drops about four frames
per second more so it's definitely
usable especially if you go into better
performance is going to be perfect um
all right so this can't handle it let's
go ahead and export this project let's
see what happens
well i was shocked to see that once
again it beat it out only by two seconds
this time but it's still beat it out i'm
like how the heck is this happening and
i'm like all right let's just go to
h.264 this time those are slower
encoders h.i.265 is fast it's still
beaded out what is going on
i i'm just i'm just flabbergasted at
what is happening in this comparison
this is where the mac pro should have
been winning and it's not and now let's
flip to pro res raw the macbook pro now
has prores raw encoders and decors built
in whereas for this mac pro it's two
thousand dollars for the afterburner
card and of course you guys saw the cpu
performance gpu performance all of that
so let's see what happens well with a
five minute 4k graded project
the macbook smokes the mac pro a minute
and four seconds compared to a minute
45. now that's a minute 45 with that 2
000 add-in card if you don't use the
add-in card it's two minutes and 45
seconds so an even bigger difference
almost three times longer which is crazy
and i'm like all right we we just got we
let's set this up let's go to 8k
progress raw and we're going to export
to pro res
444 xq
this five minute project is like 215
gigabytes in size when you export it
huge file sizes and well here's what
happened the macbook was more than twice
as fast at exporting this five minute
graded 8k project
and that's with the afterburner without
the after burner the mac pro takes 20
minutes so it's almost four times faster
and that is when i realized well
this mac pro i had a hard time selling
it before
i keep getting people reaching out to
want to buy it and then they look into
the new m1 systems n1 pro and max they
watch these videos that i make right
here and they literally say hey sorry
i'm buying a new macbook hey sorry i'm
going to buy this machine over here i'm
buying an imac mac mini and now these
new macbooks
it is just literally i had three people
that were serious about buying it and
then they were hey sorry i saw videos
blah blah blah i'm not gonna buy them
like hey i don't blame you it sucks for
me uh because it's a very expensive
machine and i don't really need it i
don't want to throw it out like you guys
might have saw in the thumbnail
but at this point even for the toughest
tests
everything we do
the macbook beats it in a 3500 package
with the display speakers webcam battery
it's portable it is just absolutely
insane what apple has done
and it just
it is just doing an amazing amazing job
so good job apple it's great that we can
get such killer performance for the
money even the mac pro is now for most
tasks uh taken out unless you want to
buy like the 28 core you know it's over
50 g's if you fully spec it out in that
case of course if you want to have four
graphics cards in there uh if you need
one and a half terabytes of ram if you
need pci slots this thing still has a
place um so there's definitely people
that still need to buy this but judging
on who's been reaching out to buy for me
those people are few and far between all
right guys thank you for watching if you
guys want to help us reach our goal of 1
million subscribers please click that
subscribe button above we would greatly
appreciate it check out our merch down
below as well as the links check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you